[Music]
time now for a final exam we troll the
hallways of Fox News to find the
smartest people bring them here for a
tight antic clash of news personalities
this week's two-time defending champion
is Carly Shimkus Fox News headline 24/7
reporter and contributor to Fox and
Friends her challenger is the political
editor of townhall any Fox News
contributor guy Benson smart people both
and ferociously competitive are you
ready you're ready okay so you've been
reigning champion yes guy has come in to
dethrone Ian I'd like to cling on to
that title okay good
well we'll see a few of the students
were time off necessary and the news
knowledge okay hands on buzzers here are
the rules you're familiar but I'm just
telling you just there are no mistakes I
ask the questions the first one to buzz
in gets to answer you have to wait till
I finish asking the question before you
do each correct answer is worth 1 point
get it wrong you lose a point best of 5
wins are you ready ready let's get
started
the White House recently asked the
Guggenheim to borrow a painting by
Vincent van Gogh the famous one eared
Dutch painter when you see him declined
instead offered President Trump which
piece of so-called art Carly a 18 karat
gold toilet don't believe you that's too
grotesque we'll check the tape see if
you're right an 18 karat fully
functioning gold toilet this work of
ours can displayed in a public restroom
at the Guggenheim and it had been used
by thousands of people at some Blair
House you know 18 karat I just that's a
level of nyssa tea that we're not you
know we don't deal with that currency
here the old toilet is impressive enough
question two this week for the first
time in 150 years a blue moon a super
moon and a lunar eclipse occurred
simultaneously on the same night there's
a name for this phenomenon what is it
guy Benson is a super blue blood moon
it's too weird but let's see if you're
right to the tape you're looking at the
super blue blood moon is the first time
we've seen this in the US and more than
150 years and here's what it looks like
right here above New York that's really
cool how'd you know that because someone
made the joke that I'm sort of blue
blooded and said this is my moon Wow
you can this speaks to you too I know
this no I see a super blue blood bad
moon rising kind of thing yeah question
three
this one is multiple choice at one hour
and 20 minutes
president Trump State of the Union
address was long but it was not the
longest in history which former
president still holds that title is it
Bill Clinton George W Bush or Barack H
Obama that been so Bill Clinton sure I
think so
wait no what no equivocating in your
answers is it Bill Clinton the hour and
20 minutes speech the third longest
state-of-the-union ever behind two Bill
Clinton's speeches oh so he's got spots
1 & 2 1 & 2 yeah Wow that's Clintonian
okay I'm not surprised actually Obama I
felt like yeah I know no he was a worthy
character but nobody beats Clinton in
that category
dude why no question for one Democratic
congresswoman is so offended by
President Trump she says a parental
advisory ought to be aired before his
speeches
who is this congresswoman Josephine
Waters Maxine Waters of Los Angeles is
it Maxine Waters
this president with his vulgarity and
his disrespect for women and people of
color is a terrible role model for our
children whenever he appears on TV there
should be a disclaimer that says
this may not be acceptable for children
yes vaccine that's not extreme
no totally cheered on a race ride that's
not offensive okay so are we to to to I
think we are leave check on the judges
we are they've confirmed that it's two
to two this is the tiebreaker question
five my final question palms are
sweating okay here it is a video of a
rat the rodent went viral this week
because the rat was caught doing
something pretty extraordinary what was
the rat doing it was a rat was doing
something extraordinary an actual okay
this is this is gonna be risky because I
know I'd be dr. Point right if I get a
would in fact indeed you would lose I
would would but you've pressed so I have
to answer I there's something in the
back of my mind that says that I read
something about something to do with a
cigarette he had a cigarette does not
Pizza rat but I've been cigarette round
was the rat smoking a cigarette by the
way if you roll your own counts too it
doesn't matter any kind of cigarette was
the rat smoking it's really important
that you're properly clean especially if
you're a kind of hairy like this fella
look at him preparing for his date he's
getting all the important spots he's you
know he just got out of a bad marriage
and he just met somebody online what a
clean but bold I think he was like
hitting the cocaine bar but no I want to
see the video of the rat smoking the
cigarette
I saw something it might have been a
joke based on that but someone tweeted
something about this it was a bold yes
but in the end it did not pay off it was
the etoys of this vigil I thank you so
much for ownership this you remain third
week in a row oh my gosh it's
unbelievable and again the coveted
mouth-breathing mug my cupboards are
full get ago give them to your friends
thank you both very much that was great
thank you so much pay attention to the
news each and every week tune in every
Thursday to compete against our
contestants